now they're trying to tell you they're
trying to give you a clue right that I
mean obviously you could write out the
entire expansion and then say okay look
X cubed there it is and you can write
out a coefficient okay but knowing these
kinds of properties and understanding
there's a pattern here that we can sort
of take advantage of right it's a little
bit like how we learn you know when you
learned that the sum of a GP is this
right you don't have to work out the
first 10 terms and then add up all
individually you just take any quest and
then plug it in right so we're trying to
do the same thing here but with buy very
much now to try and understand how do I
do this
right how many terms are you going to
get out of this at the end if the power
of is 5 up here right how many terms
will there be in turtle when we did a
plus B whole square right how many terms
are there at the end is a squared is 2 a
B and this B squared right so there's
going to be 3 terms out of this so
there's n plus 1 terms if you're raising
to the power of M okay now the first
term will be X to the 5 then X to the 4
and then X to the 3 so then X to the 3
that's the one we want right we're after
that coefficient okay now because all of
these diagonals at the front are in the
format and choose whatever okay you want
to think about what which term my up to
the first term has n to 0 the second
term has n choose 1 and the third term
has n choose 2 right now X cubed in this
expansion we define X to the 4 plus X to
the 3 right you see that term whatever
coffee
that's the third term okay so therefore
the first thing the right is 5 choose 2
I'm choose to that's gonna be the number
on the front alright no then you're
gonna get this combination right you're
gonna get the a and the B in differing
amounts okay
the a here is our X right so I don't
actually want that in here I'll look the
coefficient of x cubed okay but you
don't just get the execute you also get
some of this guy right now the question
is how many of him do I get what power
do I have to raise it to the answer is
two now how can you see that well the
first thing is remember we worked out
our this is the third term right so
therefore this number down here was 3-1
okay and that's the same number you get
up here see how that one y ends up with
this one and in fact there's even a B to
the power of 0 which also lines up with
that zero right
so therefore this is going to be 5
choose 2 times 2 square now I think
rememory flexures 2 is 10 and that's 4
so the coefficient I'm after is 40
that's all there is to it okay much
quicker than actually writing on every
single term okay but it starts to get a
little trickier when you've got more
complicated binomials than this okay so
flicker eyes over to Part C and the
binomial they give us is 2x minus 1 to
power 7 no because this power is
different right the power of 7 it's not
gonna be the third term anymore it'll be
a different time right I'm not starting
at X to the 5 I'm gonna start at x 7
okay so I'm still after the X cubed term
so which term is it it's the one two
three four fifth term okay so what am I
going to have out the front in which is
seven choose the victor
it's gonna be four in there just like
that two of course must use the third
term okay now cuz of that for I can
immediately see this four is the same as
so
this too is the Thames is 2 so this 4 is
gonna be the same as at this power in
the end right minus 1 to the power 4
don't forget the minus sign because
obviously if it was an odd number that -
I would make a difference right but we
should not be negative in this case
first even know primes
okay so so far I have the same efficient
here as I did here but I'm missing
something what do I have to take into
account yeah good so I've got um I've
got that pesky to the front right now
how many twos will I have answer 3
because I've got 3 X's right remember
I'm after the coefficient of x cubed so
since I've got 3 X's I'm going to get 3
screws as well so I should have 2 cubed
on the end of here does it matter what
order you do these numbers in not really
because it's just multiplication right
but it's customary to put them in chute
NCR notation out the front I personally
put this coefficient here because that 4
and therefore the same ok so I try and
get them together because under the
numbers going to match all right now
what does that equal to a big number
what's it equal to 2 I mean this is the
one which was wrong I think the answer
actually say 140 which is